and if you will give me a few moments i
will start our linkedin live stream for
our
live streaming audience
we're also live on
youtube
one moment
we're hoping to
start using uh
a different
webinar tool in the near future but uh
for today we're using
webex and there are certain limitations
which
i've just been
working through here to get the live
streaming started
and
unfortunately
they led to some
minor frustrations this uh
evening with uh
dr singh so
we are now live
okay welcome to our linkedin live
audience our youtube audience and our
webex live audience
um to our
career webinar
which is what's your story
and
this is about personal impact for
professional success
uh our speaker today is
dr mainachala singh
scholar in residence at american
university i'll tell you a little bit
more about her before
she begins but first i want to just
mention to our
webex audience if you have questions for
dr singh please put them in the
q a panel of the webex tool
and we'll be able to get to those if you
uh have chats or if she asks you a
question that
needs a
chat response you could do that in all
panelists in the chat function if you're
watching on live stream uh do feel free
to enter
poll question answers and such in
the
comments of your
live stream tool
and i'm going to ask a first poll
question before we get started so that
um
maina has an idea of who is in our
audience and
this is a poll question if you're on
webex you'll see the pull widget now
uh two parts one is how many years of
experience do you have
in work
and
second part of the question we do this
check-in we have been during the
pandemic um
see how people are holding up with
surges rising and falling and new
variants coming out practically every
week
you want to see how people are holding
up to
the changes in their work environment
personal lives
and just getting a check in on your
status
so i'll close the poll in about five
seconds
and
here is our
whole result
so mino we have a very experienced
audience today
almost two-thirds of our audience are
people with five or more years of
experience
and that's uh uh
that gives you an idea of who's
here today
and what stage of their career they're
in
um and
fortunately
um about 90 of our audience says they're
doing well or doing okay
and we hope this
career webinar will will
help improve the outlook for the people
in that third category so
with that
i'm gonna introduce myself my name is
stuart creek i am a marketing manager
here at simply learn
and
i'm here today with
dr maina chala singh who is the scholar
in residence
at the school of international service
of american
university and
she has if you adjust my camera here
over 25 years of teaching experience
um in
several countries around the world
she
is an expert in both transnational
education and design of
that type of
in-person curriculum but she's also an
expert in
online curriculum and ed tech
and today she's going to be talking
about
the importance of
storytelling in your personal branding
so
welcome mine i'm going to stop sharing
my screen because we don't need to be
staring at slides we're going to be
having a conversation
and
welcome i'm glad to have you here today
uh you are you are mute by the way i'm
sorry
let me unmute you
yeah there you go go ahead
so thank you stuart uh
it's been amazing getting your support
before we actually
uh came on to this session and there
were a couple of questions saying when
is the meeting starting and i remember
said a minute later and i think there
must be a lot of people there who work
in technology and software and coding
how do i know that because i've been
looking at previous seminars so webinars
so i know that a lot of people uh who
are techies um are on this platform i
just want to say to you that we've just
had terrible terrible glitches with uh
with our technology and uh you know i'm
beginning with a story as you can see
because i logged in and we had a dry run
and we had it all sorted out and i had a
lovely background i thought everything
was all done to the tea
and then i log in 20 minutes ahead of
time and i say oh this is going to be a
breeze it's all going to
go smoothly and we've not been able to
do that so i have to say first that i'm
on a smartphone so we had to kick in our
you know plan b i'm on the smartphone
some of my notes are on my laptop and
i'm basically just in a dizzy that's my
story before the story that's a smaller
story of saying okay i'm thrilled to be
here but this is what happened to us
so
hello everyone from all different parts
of the world i'm so delighted that
you're making the time to join us i'm
actually in india so i'm sort of in
between those various timings of the far
east and
north america and
the west
coast so i was taking a look at the
previous courses and i saw that this is
a global audience i saw that people have
amazing skills because
uh the courses were about machine
learning about crypto about java python
a lot of languages that i do not
understand and i thought to myself you
know it would be great to talk about
something which does not need many many
slides but it's about
not about the products you create and
the codes you create but it's about you
it's about you the the analyst it's
about you the coder
and if we were in person i would have
asked each one of you what is your story
uh you know when you appear as a
professional
you need a projection
that projection which is a little bit
beyond the qualifications that you have
on paper the expertise you have in terms
of your profession and your subject you
need a narrative you need a story
not one which you fabricate
it's facts it's not fiction but it has
design
it's crafted from the facts and the
events in your life from your experience
and what you do is weave them together
intricately because that's what our
lives are they're about a whole bunch of
experiences some that we remember and
some that are embedded within us but
they left something really important of
a change in us
i'm using these metaphors deliberately
because you know often during my
mentoring sessions people say
you know i don't really have an
interesting story or they'll say i have
to write this application and i'm going
to
do an mba or something else or i'm going
to this
get together and i know that over this
retreat we'll be talking about different
things and i don't really have an
interesting story
so what do i do
and i just want to say that we all have
stories and they are unique stories
so strategies to project your profile
that's one of the things we're talking
about so this session is really how
how to create a personal narrative what
strategies to use secondly why do you
even need one
thirdly
when can you use the story
i'm dr maynard chawla singh as stewart
said i have been
an academic researcher i've done
field work research my degree is span
across various subjects in liberal arts
i have lived in
seven different countries as diverse as
russia and ethiopia
to north america and france so
i bring to you multiple perspectives of
the way that i have mentored and taught
young people and many of them now have
put in 10 years of work in different
parts of the world in different
industries luxury
in
healthcare in
fintech in edtech and i now work for an
edtech startup here in delhi
so let's
get started step one creating your
personal narrative
my story how do you do that
the first step is reflect
reflect and revisit what you're going to
do
you're at point x
today
so you're going to think backwards
how did you get here i don't just mean
all the degrees you have and the five
years of experience or eight years but
how did you get here do you have a dream
was a certain break you got that was
amazing that changed everything
was it a sudden twist in circumstances
did you have to relocate and suddenly
everything changed after that
was it a setback
in your life in your personal life in
your professional life was there a
particular company you loved and they
had to they went under and then you had
to restart and shift gears i don't know
this happens to people with five years
of work experience 10 15 20 anything
was there a point where you felt there
was a failure did you make a mistake at
work
would you still remember was there an
accident
something unintentional
something when
when things seemed to crumble
so revisit something
that's important that stuck with you
well you know if you're writing this or
if you're sorry if you're if you're
listening to us and if you are if you
are sitting down to write a story
clearly things did not crumble
and even if they did
you clearly did something
to restore it to rebuild
to reframe to reframe your vision to
readjust your priorities
and to basically change your strategy
so reflect on the unforgettable
experiences
moments
challenges
you wanted a job and you didn't get it
how did that change did you want to go
to a particular university and that
never happened
and sometimes you look back and say
thank god because what happened
afterwards was amazing
or basically that taught you something
to bounce back
so think of the challenges
the triumph
the surprise that you got in being
handed a project and how you aced it and
how amazing that was
what did that teach you success
what was the lesson from success
humility
maybe not why not
so think of the setbacks the triumphs
the challenges
and that's your unique collection of
stories
it's authentic and if it's authentic
it will be compelling
because it's you
it's different you are unique your set
of stories is going to be unique
so i have a tip here be authentic
write about things that are plausible
you know when people write on linkedin
about achievements that are through the
roof and then you realize that actually
anybody who's been through 10 15 years
of work experience can really see
through that
we can see through all those big words
and the hyperbole and the exaggeration
and so on so talk about your
achievements that seem doable
um
watch out for them on those linkedin
profiles and say no i'm not going to do
that you know there is a fine line
between too much self-praise
and pride in one's achievement
find that line for yourself
okay so what are you going to do with
these stories
uh
[Music]
list them out
list them out
about when
that
event happened that challenge that
triumph when did that happen
what age
were you very early in your career were
you finishing your grad school was there
you know did the pandemic really slow
thing down did you lose something did
you have to re pivot did you have to do
what did you have to do so think of that
time in your life and also think of that
time in a broader context
maybe it was related to a recession
maybe it was related to uh to an econo
economic downturn what was it political
events what was going on
from that you get a context
and you get a cold moment
on which you're able to hinge
so what's going on
and what happened those are the two
things now when you have that step back
step back into the present
where you are
and ask yourself
what do i want to highlight
you have all these moments
which are the ones you think are really
salient
that you feel
something happened there which
contributed to who i am today
i can see a few questions coming up or
some comments i want to say that because
i'm on a smartphone screen i will not be
able to look at them while i speak but
in a short while i will or maybe i will
take steward's help at the end so if i
don't stop now to respond to you it's
because i'm i have half a half a phone
screen to look at so i'm just going to
speak for a little while and we'll
uh
questions and comments so
i'll keep track of that for you thank
you thank you i just wanted to be
respectful of the of the audience and to
say that you know i i have a little
story around the presentation in terms
of a sequence of the thoughts i want to
share and i would like to
continue with that for a little while
more and then we'll have a couple of
breaks so once you have those and you
have a list of those experiences ask
yourself what do i want to highlight
transformation
do you want to highlight something that
transformed you
from what to what
write those qualities
second
do you want to talk about growth
did you grow as a result
of that story
that's your story then it's a growth
story
did that event or whatever happened
did that change your relationship to
your career
was that something happened and you said
you know what i'm working i'm hustling
and i really want to rethink and it
changed your priorities and you feel
that your focus today is deeper and
stronger and that's the learning you
have
and so that's a learning that you should
be proud to talk about and say i have my
priorities i love my work
but i also love life
and i have found my own balance
so think about that so first tip is
think of it as was there a
transformation second was there is a
growth
was there a change in your relationship
to your career
was there a change in your relationship
to money very often that changes a lot
of things for you so think about money
think about wealth accumulation was
there something that you learned because
there was a tragedy or there was
something you saw maybe in your life
maybe in somebody else's life
that made you realize that money is
finite that there is a point beyond
which it cannot really cannot buy
everything sometimes you want things
that you can't buy with money
was there a relationship at work that
completely made you think differently of
work maybe a boss maybe a subordinate
maybe something that happened to them
was there a mental health thing you know
that today mental health is something
that everybody is speaking about with
honesty and authenticity and is okay
not to be okay
so is there something there that you can
think about or just your relationship to
life so think of those experiences and
what they
did and those are going to be your
narratives
that is how you're going to curate
your story
stuart
your thoughts is there something you'd
like to add at this point or you'd like
me to add
well so uh we talked about
why a story is important
my camera back on
and how to craft it
how do professionals use that story what
is the
what are some of the the techniques they
can use to apply the story and and
up the game professionally maybe use it
to
advance their reputation within their
company or find a new job or just move
their career ahead
and
up their game professionally basically
thank you that's that's really on point
uh it's really the purpose of why people
sign up to listen to these things and
spend an hour doing that so why is your
story important you know
reflect on the most representative
challenges setbacks successes
resilience
and especially success did that teach
you something
something important
now why is all this important i want to
look at the larger context you know the
job scenario has changed people want to
know
who you are they want to know your
coping skills they want to know your
motivations they want to know your
dreams and aspirations
why do you think they want to know this
because you're going to be part of a
team they want to know what that person
is like
do they even does she even have dreams a
vision because that shows a growth
mindset so don't just say i have a
growth mindset tell me a story don't
just say i'm resilience and i face many
challenges tell me one of them show me
how it happened and that's your unique
story again i want to say that you know
your cv your cv is really a dead
document in today's dynamic digital aid
your cv is something you send and they
use ai and they look at keywords and
they have 500 cvs and who knows
but you have a chance to create a story
your story is alive it's dynamic it's
not just a list of your qualifications
and i'm going to say give you a few tips
about how you can use them when can you
use them so i want to say that you know
the earliest stage if you've done five
years of work experience and you still
want to go for something that's deeper
in advance any application of any level
is going to want a story that's at the
earliest level then i want to say think
about the stock interview questions tell
us about yourself what you're going to
do
that's where you pick on a quality
you use two qualities as entry points
and say i have a story that connects
both these
qualities that today i'm very proud that
i keep working on whether it's a growth
mindset whether it's resilience
whether it's humility
whatever you want to say so begin with
two of them and bring your story there
what you need to show at an interview or
you know an interview can also be very
subtle it can also be a conversation
that um
somebody very senior is having with you
because they want you to be on the
senior most leadership team that's also
so when i say interview i mean really a
broader conversation where people are
actually assessing you in a very good
way but they want to know who you are so
typically the fact that you want to keep
learning the fact that you your
motivation is strong
the fact that you know how to deal with
setbacks and failure
that's where you need a story so it's
not just grad students who need it we
need stories all the way then i want to
say that you know professional
interactions for example conference
dinners
business lunches retreats even team
socials
where the senior leadership is really
trying to see who's doing how well
those are your occasions
to think of where you can actually use a
story be careful not to insert it in a
very
um
obtrusive way not very obvious but very
often people are sharing things and
that's when you can actually make an
insertion and say something similar
happened to me and then you can bring in
a very short story make sure that your
audience
is listening to you which means keep
your story short
give them a little snippet and if it's
interesting you'll see how people will
ask you questions and say what happened
afterwards and that's when you know that
you're telling a story really well so i
think you can use them at various levels
i want to say that you can if you're at
a junior level or mid-level it's
something you can use to showcase that
you're ready for leadership if you're
already in the leadership room then you
use it to inspire managers
i have a tip for you define your
audience think of who you're talking to
it will be different at a team social
it'll be different if you're part of a
board meeting so use the data of your
own story to create a personal brand
so i want to now just
conclude with a couple of
recaps is finally i think there are
three qualities about yourself
that you need to showcase here
curiosity
it shows that you're an explorer learner
enthusiastic
aspiration
it shows that you have goals
you have a vision
that drives you and growth
it shows that what you can do what you
have done
and that dreams are driving you
so is there a poll we should do before i
say um two three final words stewart
what do you think
i think that um
there is a poll that you
asked
us to set up and i'm gonna do that right
now
okay
so
this is a poll for the audience
okay
and i'm just going to take a minute so
that you can set up the poll
and i just want to say finally that um
you know power today
power real power whether it's leaders or
social media power is about holding
attention
attention is really scarce because we
are all tired of paying attention so
that's where it is your power is about
holding attention and that's about
distilling facts data ideas into a story
a story that holds attention
and i want you to just look at that poll
hold on for just a moment while i okay
okay so i'm just going to say a couple
of things more and finish off just think
of what digital marketing is doing today
it's absolutely going through the roof
and why is that it's telling about it's
telling a brand story
and so i want to say as a career mentor
i want to say to you that you are the
brand
build yourself
we all have a treasure of stories so dig
into them
craft your own you have the fabric now
weave the tapestry
and you will create i'm sure
a personal brand which is both unique
and compelling
so i want you to look at this bowl
give me a moment here we're having a
little technical difficulty
i will start looking at um
[Music]
now i have mohammed tahil i have nitin i
have
anderson
and i just want to acknowledge as many
as i can
abdullahi abdul abhishek
i would love to know um
how many of you just just
can we do some countries here in the
chat box so i know which countries
you're logging in from that would be so
nice
while we set up
oh lovely i have canada i have india
kuwait texas wow texas is a country oh
no don't do that to me
okay lovely lovely nebraska
uh india mexico bangalore hyderabad
wonderful
wonderful wonderful
uh when no one's support to hear your
story then this is lakshmi that panda
who's asking me when no one is there to
support to hear your story so lakshmi
that i don't know whether you mean
is there someone to
hear your story or someone to help you
write that story i'm going to answer
both i'm going to say
that your story is something you need to
write yourself because nobody can nobody
knows the experiences you've had when
you say hear your story you know i want
to say that whether it's your colleagues
or your bosses
they do want to know who you are you
just have to be clever about where
you're going to put in what story and
actually i don't really mean tell a
story i want to say that
we ourselves are a brand
we have a story with different events in
our story
different
moments and different experiences
and all of those stories make
one story that is me that is you
and nobody else so i'm going to look at
a couple of other
things here oh wonderful lots of people
here
um israel aha shalom shalom interesting
so i
some of the countries i've lived in are
here no i've not lived in mexico of
course india yes i've been to turkey
beautiful country i've lived and taught
in the us yes i've lived in israel
canada sorry i miss me seeing canada i
haven't been there
um okay how to build a corporate
relationship you know when you say
corporate relationship that's kind of
hard you mean work in a corporate
or build relationships within a
corporate
that question is not very clear so when
you say corporate relationship i guess
if you mean get a job in the corporate
world that's a whole other conversation
but if you mean relationship between
corporations
that has to be built over time depending
on the dealings you have with them
actually relationship building is a
whole other conversation
and if you put it in the polls maybe we
can have a conversation about
relationship building and networking
skills you know networking is a word is
a term that is used all the time and
networking can actually be done really
badly by people when they don't realize
that network is not about going and
exchanging cards very often at
conferences people give in and exchange
cards or you have
linkedin followers or you have linkedin
networks that really is not a network
a real network is when you build trust
when they know you and they want to work
with you they want to deal with you they
know what you do and so when something
similar happens they think of you
that is how you build networks and
relationships and i'm going to now look
at a couple of other things here
um
[Music]
uh
[Music]
let me just see are they
questions that i'm missing i'm still
working on my little phone screen
[Music]
okay so
if you would respond to this uh poll
that would be interesting are you
interested
in learning soft skills like profile
building act in
acing online interviews i've had a lot
of young people who've said that
interviews are very frightening
they've also said that they're not very
confident about making presentations or
having online interviews
and these are people who are very very
accomplished so you know
those are things that i just wanted to
know from you is that something that
also
um bothers you or is something that you
feel that
you know sometimes we have excellent
skills and expertise in our profession
in our domain
but we are not as confident about
giving it exposure
because we don't know when it's
self-advertisement
and when it's okay and how is it okay
to speak about yourself without sounding
like you're being bombastic or you're
showing off or
i'm sure you've run into people who
you've suddenly moved away from and said
oh my god this person is so full of
themselves so that's why i put some of
these things in the poll
and uh stewart do we have some questions
that i can look at here
okay i found some questions here
um oh i have someone here from swaziland
hello how are you
um or is
no
i'm sorry did i make a mistake this is
actually paul
uh
who's writing this
from
swaziland
i apologize if that's a mistake all
right how to write an eye-catching cv so
i want to say that a cv is really beyond
uh the scope of this that's a whole
other thing cv writing and profile
building
uh i'll tell you maybe i can give you
one or two tips right away
you should go and take a look at some of
the templates and formats i want to say
that a cv
needs to be very well formatted it
cannot just be text it needs the bullet
points it needs to have certain fonts
don't make it flowery it needs to look
professional
don't make it so heavily textual break
the flow have a few bullet points have a
short paragraph have a few bullet points
have a short paragraph make it easy for
your recruiter or whoever is in hr
very often they'll ask you for a
one-page cv because they feel people
can't stop and they send long cv's that
are impossible to read so think of these
things think of very very good
formatting remember a cv has to look
good visually
it can be very tiring for an hr person
to look through 500 cvs so make it
easier for them so brevity formatting
structure i will leave you with that
okay
and i'm taking another question here
if you have one year experience what's
the most important part i should talk
about
you know if you have a year's experience
you have some very important moments
that help you to help you to get that
job
if you've got the job that you dreamt
about
then you need to say something about how
you got there
okay what was the work you put in
how did you strategize what are the
choices you made
if you feel this job is only a stopover
you should not say that to your boss
but you should be able to say to them
that you are looking forward to growth
and then say something about how you had
two incidents in your life from which
you learned
that growth and having goals and vision
is really important
so you focus on the future
and if somebody has 10 15 years of
experience they can focus on what
happened what taught them you can
continue to focus on growth mindset
on the dreams you have on the vision you
have and you should be able to say that
i work with a five-year set of goals in
five years i would like to be at
so-and-so point
and if all works like i plan i hope that
in ten years time i will be able to do
something very impactful but then say
don't just say i want to make an impact
and change the world those are big
claims
make your claims doable
people always respect people who have a
practical sense of
where they're going
okay does that answer the question you
want to ask something else
dream that's your question
and
um oh greetings from haiti korea
bangalore ghana
i'm so grateful and so excited i feel
i'm traveling myself
okay and of course everyone from india
hello hello hello
um
we have terrible weather these days in
india in some parts we have beautiful
rain
in other parts we have terrible tropical
humidity uae it's probably hot as much
there
um
okay so
right i have a question here from simran
how do we come to know that which kind
of story is applicable where
and also is it good to add two or more
aspects of the story or should we bring
them up one by one
you know simran i think you should think
of
the story as who you are
rather than writing a book of short
stories
think of the important moments that you
want people to know about
it doesn't mean that you have to come
tumbling out with your stories all the
time no not at all
so you choose are they talking about
you know if you think about your
conversations with your friends you will
realize that when people people are
talking about something they're talking
about money you remember a story about
money when they are talking about
parents you remember a story about
parents if they are talking about
settling abroad you will remember a
story about settling abroad so take your
cues from what is happening
the reason i
like to do this conversation with people
is because
i don't want you to think even for a
moment that you don't have an
interesting story so i wanted to speak
about how you can actually
think and remember all those things
and keep them in mind
if you write them down you won't forget
them
and you will be more aware intentionally
of those moments that made you who you
are today okay are you an optimist
because you served you you so you faced
a setback are you resilient because
there was a point of failure
who are you okay so i have some more
things here to read how do we come to
know uh this is simran's question okay
uh so you will use the applicability of
the story depending on the conversation
how um simran i have your question twice
here
why um
[Music]
why you are conducting this free seminar
is it very good you are doing free i
don't know what you mean
i don't know what you're doing that was
a good that was a question for us here
at simply learn and
i'm going to tell a story if if i take
if i may take a moment
all right i'm going to tell two stories
really quickly okay okay so let me just
go through a couple of these or do you
want to tell the story now
well i'll answer that question about the
free okay go ahead go ahead lovely first
story is about simply learning and how
it got started and it started by a
entrepreneur named krishna kumar
who had been
successful with a startup had done an
exit
was looking at what he could do next and
started
a blog on project management
and it was asked answering questions
from people around the world about
you know how do i become a better
project manager and how to
get a
certificate from the project management
institute and that type of thing and
krishna said well to himself
let's start a company to help people get
that kind of certification so he began
with a
a training company that would go from
city to city and conduct these classes
and then realized that he could help
a lot more people if he created an
online platform to do this and that's
how simply learn came to be
and the answer the question about why we
do this for free these types of webinars
and such
you have other free products
one called skill up which offers a bunch
of different um
skills training uh courses for free the
reason he does that is because he feels
the obligation
to um
share that success that he's had
over the last 11 years the company's
been around and
so
that's one of the the
reasons why all of us who work here at
simply learn take a great deal of pride
in our jobs and our company because of
that type of
founder's attitude that he still carries
with him today so
that's one story the other quick story
i'd like to tell is about how
this webex platform
which bit um
mina
earlier today uh just bit me so while i
was trying to set up the poll my webex
system crashed and i had to reboot my
laptop so
thank you for your patience i did run
the poll by the way mine it just to tell
you
what the result was
and
it looks at
about
20 percent of the audience were
interested in each of the different uh
aspects of profile building
acing online interviews and professional
branding so
i just wanted to
mention that
okay and
that that's my story for now
lovely so
stuart
thank you for sharing that story about
your founder in fact
i didn't know about it but i want to say
to
uh
a lot of people out there that you know
um
when i was in college which was a long
time ago
uh private education was hardly there we
were all the products of state education
state education meant it was highly
highly subsidized
and
um
it gave us a sense that you know we
didn't pay very much for our higher
education
and i've had all my degrees in india
although i have taught and earned abroad
from overseas universities
so i've designed courses for them i've
taught abroad but i've actually educated
in india all three my all the time my my
publications have been overseas and i'm
on the board of various journals and so
on but i take great pride in the fact
that because you grow up not feeling
that your your parents are burdened with
paying fees for your education you have
great respect for teachers because they
themselves are not very highly paid so
when the commercial aspect of higher
education
is not there in the way you think
then for me i don't teach anymore and
i'll tell you a secret it's because i
don't want to grade papers anymore but i
do a lot of advising and i do a lot of
work with researchers and people who
want to grow in scholarship especially
and for people who are building their
careers about other strategies other
skills not what they're studying what
they're studying is what they're
studying but um there is projection
that's important there are other skills
there are soft skills and so that's what
i really talk about so are there any um
other questions we have here or anybody
else like to comment on what else people
have talked about
okay i have a question here from ankur i
have failed in the past five attempts
over committed and underperformed i'm
too scared to give any commitments i
start with activity and then money
doesn't flow so i lose interest and move
again
um you know ankur when you say i failed
in the past five attempts i don't know
whether you are talking about five
different jobs
or studying or whatever but the fact
that you
see it
in that way
that you are now anxious about any
commitments
i want you to think back and say every
time that something didn't work
did you learn something did you learn
patience from it did you learn that that
is not for you
did that
um you know the important thing is to
say
how am i better for the next challenge
maybe what you've been trying the
attempts have not been
appropriate for you and your skill set
maybe it would be a good idea to have an
educational counselor or a mentor who
can actually speak to you and see where
exactly you would like to see yourself
five years from now and then help you
with a strategy about how to do those
things that will get you there okay so
the first thing is don't be disheartened
there used to be a time in india when we
were really embarrassed about anything
that didn't work today people say you
either
succeed or you learn
we don't say you succeed or you fail
you either succeed or you learn so
remember that and if you want to talk
more you'll find me on linkedin let me
look at the next question here if i
immigrate to another country how do i
show my abilities to the ideal position
so jesse when you're immigrating
uh
you will have a reason if you're going
for education you will be able to get
that admission only if you are able to
go to put in a good application if you
are immigrating just on your own they
will still want to know what you are
doing the important thing is i don't
know what stage of your career you're at
but if you're if you feel that you need
to up your
degrees
then the best thing would be to opt for
education and educational program if you
are applying for a job straight away
then you really need to reflect on your
skills you need to reflect on your story
maybe you don't have very high
educational qualifications maybe you
don't have
an advanced degree
but if you're able to show that you have
a growth mindset that you're resilient
that you are diligent and you want
success you are driven you should be
able to get a job that
that is commensurate and appropriate for
your own skill set and your
qualifications so that's my
suggestion to you
please if you don't have ex don't have
experienced and now looking for a
student work or internship what do you
do i think what you want to say is if
you have no previous work experience
and
looking for a student work oh okay as a
student if you're looking for work or
internship what do you do
so you should go online and see some of
my blogs and videos where i have spoken
about internships i have spoken about
profile building and so on and so forth
but i want to say that you have to start
looking for internships
where
which are meant for students and
freshers and there are many of them you
need to go online and look for
internships i don't know where you are
looking for in which country whatever i
also want to say that today these days
you can do something called micro
internships and i just wrote a blog and
it should be published this friday and
you can
log in my name and search
just say blogs and my name and you
should be able to find it or it may have
been published but otherwise this friday
so i think student as students and
freshers have separate set of
internships and you should go online and
look at the possibility and just write
many many many emails looking for those
a positions of questions in chat from
baskar and from juliet um and i think
that they probably address a number of
the people in the audience okay having
to do with people who are
later in their career maybe in the 40s
maybe later
oscar says you know
his experiences
seems like companies in india reject
people who are of a higher age and
greater experience level
um thinking that they're maybe
overqualified
and
something
similar juliet is asking about you know
what happens when you're at that stage
of your career and yet you feel your
skills are not
sufficient or relevant to keep to keep
going forward so
what do you do you advise for people who
are
at that stage of their careers and lives
that um
want to to revitalize their careers
yes so um julian that's um that's a
question that a lot of people have been
asking
um
i think basically it uh
the root of it is
the exponential growth in technology
and that ai has begun to power things
and augmented reality i don't know if
you're a technical person but i know
from mentoring uh
various professionals that that has been
one of the reasons that people have felt
that they have
their skills are not um
are less relevant today
i have to say that
there's no quick answer there's no quick
shortcut to that i want to say that
upskilling is critical the good news is
that upskilling today is possible
without actually going to a university
it's also possible
not to or not to spend a lot of money
getting an online degree
i think this is this is something which
is highly respected in in um
in most western countries and
increasingly in india that if you have
certifications
where you have learned the skills people
will respect your experience but you
don't need to have the certifications if
you are applying for a job or if you
feel you you've hit a level
from where other people that you're
competing with have skills that they
learnt more recently and your skills
were learned some time ago i don't want
to minimize the importance of experience
but i also want to say that the
experience can no longer just be
put as something that will pull the
entire wagon it won't do that you will
need to have a peg which is experience
and another peg which is being updated
in terms of skills you should really
look at your own profession and think of
the certifications and skills relevant
to you
it might be to do with hospitality it
might be to do with the luxury industry
it might do with healthcare and it may
be just a few certifications that are
needed you might be in hr in which case
maybe there are certain systems that are
being used now whereas things were being
done manually earlier so all of those
things that were at the discretion of
the individual are now being sorted in a
much faster way by the algorithms you
know we all know about algorithms and
the problems and we know they have
biases but you know what efficiency
counts time is money and so companies
are going to opt for that if you also
have the experience and a discerning eye
you have an edge
but it's not enough so i would suggest
look out for a few courses set yourself
a goal i also know that books which are
the huge online courses do not have a
very high success rate
people lose motivation and they don't
end up finishing them so if you are
paying now this is this is reset that
has been done psychologically if you are
paying a small amount the chances are
much higher that you will complete the
course just because free courses to keep
up the motivation if you are if you're
having if you have responsibilities and
you are not just a young student it's
much harder to complete those courses so
i would say look out for those courses
do a few certifications set yourself a
goal and say in six months i would do
these three micro certifications
and we hope that we will hear from you
all right so
i have
another um
question from the q a uh
asks
um how do you deal with failure in your
career
um and
um
add to that how do you specifically
use
storytelling and
stories of yourself and of others
to help you process failure and move
forward
um
failure is hard
and i'm not going to pretend that it's
otherwise you will see a lot of stuff on
social media on linkedin everywhere else
saying you know failure is just a step
you know look forward et cetera et
cetera be optimistic mental health etc i
do think it's important to acknowledge
that failure hurts okay so the first
thing is embrace that and say it's okay
to feel terrible it's okay to embrace
that what you wanted and what you tried
for
did not work
once you do accept it and embrace it
you should be able to say
i am not a failure
that which i did failed
that's your first strategy
separate yourself
from what happened
and say it happened
it's something that happened to you
you had pain but you are not pain
that's your first step because that
kicks in your analytical skills
and then you're ready to analyze
and say am i now fearful
am i angry
what are my emotions
write those emotions down
when you acknowledge those emotions
you allow yourself
to deal with them
and once you do it helps you
to look for other qualities in yourself
and one really important tip
stop seeing people who are reminding you
of that failure
if you're hanging around with a team
that reminds you of that spend the
minimal time if you're in that job with
them find other friends
join courses find other social
interactions
find real life in person
interactions which have nothing to do
with where the failure was
find yourself you are bigger than your
failure you are bigger than your pain
which is something that pain specialists
teach people who are terminally living
in pain and i'm drawing from that
metaphor
you are not failure
that happened
you are you
and your story
can be
carved out of that failure
that failure happened it's not here now
what are you going to do now
you have a fresh clean plate
serve yourself
what you want
believe in yourself that failure should
not define you
i would love to have that conversation
so if you want to link up at some point
i would be happy to do that
so i hope that something else
i was just going to say i put your um
linkedin
um id
and url into the um
chat so everyone has a chance to look at
that oh thank you
they'll find me by my name it's an
unusual name yeah
if they type the whole name they'll find
me
okay we're reaching time so i'm going to
um if i can i'd like to
go ahead and include the presentation
um with
let me pull up
powerpoint again
so we've done the questions and the
answers and i wanted to say thank you to
mina this has been
just a
marvelous and very inspiring
session and
she's been
extremely patient and persevered through
the technical challenges we face today
which is
i'm so grateful for so thank you for
that
and i said
put the
linkedin
profile link into the chat so that's
available to everyone here
i did want to mention
we talked about
certifications and and how you
move yourself forward and that's an
aspect of one of the things that
i talked about today
i'm going to give you an example of one
of the programs that
we do here at simply learn and this is a
high-end program in project management i
mentioned how
our company started off with
certification classes and you know how
to get your pmi
um
officials
test and
institutional certificate from
project management institute
we've moved on a great deal from there
we still offer those courses
but we've also moved to the point of
being able to offer comprehensive
programs with university partners and
here's one example which is
a postgraduate program in
project management which is
six months online work about five to ten
hours a week you meet with the live
instructors uh over the weekend a couple
of
sessions each weekend
and
you do
case studies and correct projects all
online all in a virtual environment
and it has
a number of different benefits and this
is typical of these types of programs
that we do where you have
during contact hours you learn earn
continuing education units
you you complete a capstone project and
the reason that i mentioned that is
talk about telling your story
the capstone project is basically the
story of completing the course it
applies all of the skills
that you learn along the way of that
six-month program
and you put them all together into
solving a problem that you can then
demonstrate to
your employer or a prospective employer
it's part of your story of i solved this
problem
and this is my unique solution so
these are kinds of programs that are
built in a series of courses over the
period of time that lead to a
certification that you can then
use to propel your career and this is
the kind of thing that we do so
i just wanted to mention that because
we did talk a little bit about um
certificates and i'd like to then do
this one last
poll if i may of our audience
if this
type of training or this type of
learning and skills certification is of
interest to you
and if it is when you would like to get
involved and start doing that
so what can i add a word as a former
professor or current professor
absolutely so i just want to say since i
have so many people here from so many
different countries
um
the model that um and you know i don't
work for simply learn so i'm not doing
it for that i'm really speaking as an
as um
as an experienced um academic and i want
to say that the flexibility of online
courses is something we all know
what i heard steward speak about today
in the about these courses was that
there's also going to be contact hours
and that is now increasingly a hybrid
model so when you have contact hours
with the professor it's the next best
thing to in person
so you know it's as a professor it's
terrible to teach just online courses
and get things from people and you know
we never meet them we don't know them
but if you have a few contact hours when
you get the papers you really know who
the students are they know who the
professor is so i really like the part
about contact hours it's also something
that i feel leads to higher rates of
completion you know when you are
responsible for jobs for families for
finances and you're doing courses the
first thing that falls by the wayside is
your course
because no one's watching over you but
if you know there's a contact hour and
you're going to meet your professor on
friday meet e-meet
it's a much higher level of motivation
of engagement and of fun because you
actually get to meet who that person is
and you still have the flexibility of
being able to do it from home and not
commuting and so on and so forth so
anyone who's looking for certifications
do look for courses which have this
hybrid model where there are some
contact hours that's what i would like
to say
that's an
excellent observation thank you mana and
um
more than 80 of our our audience are
interested in these types of programs
which
we offer through our website
simplylearn.net or siblingduran.com i'm
sorry um
and
what i'm going to do now is
answer another question that somebody
asked which is
when do we do a future
webinar in a similar domain
next week we will have
a webinar that's geared especially to
software developers and
particularly to our indian audience but
it is open to everyone
but
it's with avatar aurora who is a vp of
engineering at salesforce and
a person who's been responsible for
hiring
countless engineers and
she's going to share her expertise on
how to crack in a
software development interview at a
company of that level the sales force
the amazons the
google alphabet that type of thing so
um this is a great
session for anybody who's in software
development wants to be in software
development
is looking for improving their
interviewing techniques and skills to
become a better candidate
and that will be next week
we'll be sending out a follow-on email
from this webinar to everyone who's been
here so i'll try to include the link
for this upcoming webinar uh in that
follow-up email
so that you'll be able to register for
that if it's of interest
and with that
i'd like to invite everyone to follow
simply learn on facebook on twitter at
simplylearn and
linkedin simply learn you can search for
us
and
we would love to welcome you into our
learning community i i encourage
everyone to connect
um
with dr singh about um
the soft skills
development that she
is working on and the answers to your
polls on the soft skill question
um will help guide us in future webinars
so we are hopeful that we'll be able to
invite
mina back for a future webinar and
hopefully we'll be on a different
technology platform so that we don't
have to deal with
the kinds of things we dealt with today
but again i'm so grateful that you had
the patience perseverance to stick
through that um and
i want to thank you and i want to thank
all the audience
thank you it's been fun in spite of a
three-inch screen
and the the audience has been around
almost 200 of them so very very grateful
so excited and i hope you have a
wonderful evening morning afternoon
wherever you are
so thank you stuart this has been fun
and good luck everyone
just thrive thrive and do well bye bye
bye and that concludes our webinar
you